The joe rogan experience.
What's hard for people to grasp is that you don't know what's next.
It's hard,
it's scary.
It freaks people out.
So they seek,
they seek help with pills and booze and bullshit and bad relationships and drama
at work and all this nonsense that you just filling up your stupid head with
just to distract herself from this ultimate fascinating existence that we find
ourselves in where we,
we have no idea what's coming next.
We don't know what's going on right now anywhere except what's right in front of
us.
And even then the wheels of perception,
they,
the ebb and flow depending on what chemicals even deuced into your body,
whether or not he smoked a joint or ate a mushroom or you know,
there's a lot going on here.
It's not just as simple as this flat consciousness that we all agree upon
because I'm not entirely sure that other people have the same experience that I
do.
When I look at like some country music and I look at like some TV shows and I
looked at some,
I shouldn't even say country music,
a lot of pop music.
I actually probably like more country music now than I even like hot music.
We spent some good times in a country.
I'm a big Dwight Yoakam fan and I,
I like my dog's named Johnny Cash.
I mean I like some country music,
but there's some really stupid shit out there.
Why is it,
is it because they're dumber than me or they see in a different reality is
reality.
Just like your nose.
Your nose is a nose.
My nose,
his nose.
But if my nose was on your face,
I'd be like,
what do you do different?
You did something different and if you put your nose on my face you'd be like,
does some on your nose looks different or something?
It would be,
we both have a notes.
It's very recognizable.
Neither one are distinct.
There's does nothing.
You know,
like w w we don't flatten boxers,
noses or anything.
They're both pretty normal.
But I know my nose and I know your nose and I know your nose is in my nose.
How do I know that that's not like reality,
that reality?
Like what?
What other people see?
They're seeing it through a filter that makes things that suck come in at,
come out the bit a better shape.
They have a better smell to it.
Things that seems stupid to you,
to them.
It all just fits right into this neuron and this,
this uh,
this,
uh,
ability to interact with light,
accepts this shape better than that shape for some strange with orange has
always been my favorite color.
Are you seeing the same color?
I am.
Cause Ahrens such stupid.
How do you like orange?
You want an orange car?
You fucking Weirdo.
You know?
But you know what I mean?
It's like,
why would you like orange?
Is it a,
is it,
is it a taste thing or is it a taste thing and your world is different than
mine?
I think what you're mentioning is really one of the key lessons that,
but I'm mentioning his pot smoking nonsense.
Well,
I was just telling
when I was on that,
when I did my,
my last Iowasca trip in Peru and I had the vision of the Eagle and that was the
secret that he basically gave me is I'm flying along with this Condor Eagle and
the Eagle says to me,
you know,
you want to know how to see better.
You see through everybody else's eyes and the there was that everybody has their
own perception.
And to really understand what you're going through,
what they're going through and seeing,
you have to see what they see through their lens of perception.
And if you can do that,
you know,
all a lot of this hate and a lot of this anger goes away.
What you feel instead can be maybe pity.
I feel bad for this human look at the way the world appears to them.
Look at the way you know that person is so quick to anger,
so quick to hate when really you know,
they could look at the same situation with love and feel happiness.
And so it shifts your,
your kind of opinion on things,
but no doubt about it.
We look at things a different way and the recent studies on epigenetics will
show that,
you know,
things you can change the way things appear,
probably not only on a mental level but probably a genetic level based on your
epigenetic manipulation of belief.
You know,
and what you see.
And I,
I think,
you know,
Bruce Lipton's doing a lot of good research in that and that's a really exciting
field.
But you know,
just because you have a certain lens of perception doesn't mean that that can't
change with your choices and with your belief.
Yeah.
And that that change would help you.
We want to,
we want to hang onto the way we are so badly because we don't want to admit that
we were ever wrong if we'd met wherever wrong.
And then we have this reevaluation of the value of self.
Cause the value of self is very important.
And one of the important things a lot of people have said,
they're right.
They want to be right.
Like,
a lot of times you get in an argument with someone and if a certain point in
that you're like,
why are we even,
why am I upset about this?
Like I have nothing to do with this lizard that lives in fucking the Komodo
islands.
I have nothing to do with them.
But you're insisting that it lives all over the place.
And I'm telling you,
it only lives there and it's fucking zoos.
And like,
why is this even,
why is this upsetting?
What is it about this?
What's really going on here?
People,
um,
we,
we develop patterns,
you know,
and attachments.
No,
and attachments to your,
attached to the persona of the guy who's right about random facts,
you know,
so when you're attached to that and it gets challenged,
you identify with it,
that's part of you.
So it's actually threatening a piece of view,
which triggers the kind of fear mechanism.
It's fascinating.
When you talked to someone in you,
I'm mean,
I,
uh,
I would never say that I'm absolutely free of that.
Um,
I'm not free of any human emotion or so,
but,
um,
I'm pretty good at controlling that impulse.
And I'm also pretty good at not being attached to ideas until I've like really
extremely vetted them out and also vetted out the opposing idea.
But I've had conversations with people where they'll say something and be like,
I had a conversation with this kid where he was talking about a psychedelic
mushrooms and he disagreed that he was like very adamant,
very smart kid,
very young,
probably like maybe 20.
And he was talking to me about how,
you know,
I disagree with turnips.
We can as a stoned mushroom theory.
He goes,
I think it's too simplistic.
And it,
it ignores the fact that there's so many different strange things that are Uber
complex all throughout the universe.
You know,
why,
why should we assume that human beings got this way because of one compound?
And I was like,
you're right.
The fuck do I know my,
I don't know nothing about.
And he was like,
he goes,
oh,
okay.
I can respect that.
I go,
yeah,
I mean,
what,
what did I do the research?
Am I,
I don't know.
I think it's a good idea.
I think the idea is sound,
because I think that chimps,
obviously they think,
and mushrooms make me think in a completely unique way.
And I think that if a chimp ate mushrooms,
you'll probably affect the way he thinks.
I mean,
it just seems to make sense to me.
No doubt.
I mean,
we can see it.
you look at,
you look at the pictures of the dolphins who are just doing that fucking the
puffer fish toxin.
They're going to the surface and looking at their reflection,
you know,
at that,
at that point,
that has to be changing.
Some of the usual usual pattern is probably fine,
Trish.
Trish,
let's find fish.
Oh,
let's play.
Fuck,
let's talk.
That's fine.
Fix Your fucking,
and then all of a sudden they stop all that and it quiets and they say,
wow,
look at me.
I'm a fucking dolphin.
And then it's a different pathway that opens up and that's what happened to
these monkeys to at a certain point or humanoids or whatever,
what stage they were on.
At certain point they're like,
Ooh,
yeah.